can you tell what's wrong with this
picture of our 2D friend they live in a
flat world where there is height and
width but no depth which means that this
hat is as illegal as wearing mismatched
shoes or as incomprehensible as wearing
your cat's Christmas sweater this
portion of the hat is causing the
problem it cannot pass in front of the
head because everything must lie flat on
the plane this image is an emergency
because it implies that a section of the
brain is missing and has been replaced
by a hat instead from now on all hats
will be drawn either on top of the head
like this or as is increasingly trendy
like this backwards hats will be drawn
like this or this now for another
question if a 2d creature wore pants
would they wear them like this or like
this I'm afraid most other options would
fall off